Imagina pasar siete años en MIT y sus laboratorios de investigación
sólo para descubrir que eres un un intérprete de performances.
(Risas)
También soy ingeniero de sistemas,
y puedo elaborar varias clases de arte con la computadora.
Y pienso que lo que más me interesa
es tratar de encontrar la forma
de hacer de las computadores una forma personal de expresión.
Y muchos de ustedes, dirigentes de Macromedia y Microsoft,
de alguna forma son mi pesadilla:
Creo que hay un gran fuerza homogenizante
que el software impone sobre la gente y limita su forma de pensar
sobre lo que es posible en una computadora.
Por supuesto, también es una gran fuerza liberadora que hace posible
publicaciones y todo eso, estándares y demás.
Pero, de alguna manera, las computadoras posibilitan más
de lo que la mayoría de la gente piensa, y mi arte se ha centrado
en intentar encontrar una forma personal de usar la computadora,
así que termino escribiendo programas para lograr eso.
Chris me pidió que hiciera una performance corta
así que sólo tomare este tiempo -- tal vez 10 minutos --
para hacerlo, y al final espero tener un momento, quizás,
para mostrarles un par de mis otros proyectos en video.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Tenemos aún como un minuto
Me gustaria mostrarles in clip de mi más reciente proyecto.
Hice una performance con dos cantantes
que se especializan en hacer ruidos extraños con la boca.
Y esto recién salio el pasado mes de septiembre en ARS Electronica;
lo repetimos en Inglaterra.
Y la idea es visualizar detrás de ellos su discurso y canción
con una pantalla grande.
Usamos un sistema de rastreo visual por computadora
para saber dónde estaban.
Y porque sabemos dónde están sus cabezas,
y tenemos un micrófono inalámbrico en ellos
desde donde procesamos el sonido,
podemos crear visualizaciones
que están conectadas muy estrechamente a lo que están haciendo con su discurso.
Este tomará unos 30 segundos.
Él está haciendo una especie de sonido moviendo las mejillas.
Bueno, baste decir que no todo es así, pero es parte de ello.
Muchas gracias. Hay mucho más.
Ya me pasé de tiempo, solo quería decir que si estás en Nueva York,
puedes ver mi trabajo en la Whitney Biennal la semana entrante,
y también en Chelsea en la Bitforms Gallery.
Y con esto, creo que debería ya ceder el podio,
así que gracias de nuevo.